[Music]  foreign  [Music]  tucked away in india's northern state of  himachal pradesh is an area called the  spiti valley which translates as the  middle land  this mountainous region bordering india  and tibet is strikingly beautiful but  incredibly remote  in fact it's one of the most sparsely  populated regions in all of india  but even here in the small remote  village of hikim there is one building  that you might find very familiar  [Music]  open 12 months a year every day from 10  to 4 the post office is actually a part  of rinshin's home so the commute is  pretty easy  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  on top of distributing letters rinchen  also handles passports for the locals in  town and all of the money deposits and  withdrawals  even though the post office is small he  still needs some help  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  record  [Music]